hello everyone and welcome to today's
live broadcast give koel v-max lentil
viral production system presented by
Jung Chang ji a scientist in the Life
Sciences Solutions Group at Thermo
Fisher Scientific we are excited to
bring you this educational web seminar
presented by lab rats
this event is sponsored by thermo Fisher
Scientific and this live broadcast is
brought to you by lab Roos before we
begin I would like to remind everyone
that this event is interactive we
encourage you to participate by
submitting as many questions as you want
and anytime you want during the
presentation just click on the green Q&A
button located in the lower left of the
presentation window and type your
question into the box that appears on
the screen will answer as many questions
as we have time for at the end of the
presentation also please notice that you
will be viewing the presentation in the
slide window to enlarge the window just
click on the screen icon located in the
lower right if you have trouble seeing
or hearing the presentation please click
on the support button at the top right
of the presentation window or use the
Q&A button to let us know that you're
having a problem now please welcome me
and join in please join me in welcoming
dr. Jung Chang ji I will now turn the
presentation over to him Thank You
Christy good afternoon my name is Yong
Chun ji I'm a scientist to hearing some
of you scientific today I will introduce
you our newly developed product
the chemical airway Maps Lindiwe
reproduction system now to start with to
start with we live in a very exciting
area of sales therapy which greatly
lifts us the ability to cure cancers now
t-cell receptor and car key research has
been a hot spot in both basic and
clinical research the basic concept of
t-cell therapy that t-cells can be
extracted from the patient and undergoes
genetic modification
and theythey how's the TCR world then
get infuse into the patient's where they
can recognize and kill kill cancer cells
so from concept is really three four
possess but if we look at manufacturing
it's a whole lot complex for example arm
and you think about how to isolate and
activate the T cells and you need to
think about how to introduce your gene
of interest into the cells which
involved in a lot of genetic cell
engineering work and in the following
step we need to think about how to grow
and expand the cell so we have enough
modified he sells for treatment and the
subsequent ensure quality control and
characterization and so on release
multi-step and multi factor process in
some official scientific here we put
huge effort into the cell engineering
especially on gene theory part and we
hope we can move the sales and sales
therapy forward by providing great
product that enable customer to cure
more cancers so for today's talk I will
focus on our newly developed and lengthy
war production system to put everybody
on the same page I want to briefly
introduce Howell and he works basically
Linda Juarez vector is a modified
genetic carrier that deliver your gene
of interest into the t-cells here we
have a ninety back Linda Juarez vector
once it encounter the T cell it will
feels into the cell membrane and release
its genetic content your this is an RNA
molecule and this re will undergo
cellular processing and get integrated
into the genome and subsequently
expressed on the cell membrane in this
particular case it is the chimeric
antigen receptor in short walk are
expressed
cell membrane and these cars enabled the
T cells ability to recognize cancer
cells for typical clinical trial early
several meetings of this type of
modified cells are needed per kilo of
patient per treatment
so to modify this many T cells we also
need meetings of volunteers vectors to
deliver our gene of interest which leads
to our effort to deliver and to produce
the web high yield Linda wah
reproduction system so currently most
people are using the third-generation
production system which Co introduced
four classmates into the heck - 9 3
divide mammalian cells on the upper left
here is a schematic of all four
classmate so the transfer classmate
contains your gene of interest while the
packaging process made actually
contained cue plasmid which encode the
gap poor and ref gene of the Lenti virus
and the post + mate is the envelope
plasmid which encode the we SVG gene to
produce identifiers so you need to all
four plus may need you to be cool
transplant affected into the same cells
and then you wait let the cell
synthesize and secrete virus e and you
harvest the wireless in the culture
supernatant there are several versions
of tonight's resells system in the on
the market now so some people using
adhering to nursery cells or to natural
t-cells and while others prefer to use
adapted to nursery suspension system and
the thermo Fisher provides both both
solutions for both adhering and
suspension systems for
adherent production we have the leaf
Factory in 3,000 transduction radiant
which is which has been proven to be a
very valuable tool the tide
yo these were high it works great with
large inserting and the Radian actory is
worth gent also which is critical for
maintaining a healthy culture and also
we used reduced region dose which is
great for long term cost saving working
with the effect Amin 3000 is quite
straightforward you just cool transact
the Pope last matey with the flattening
3000 p3000 combination and they wait the
two nine three T or two and three F T
cells to produce your virus and the u
k-- retrovirus and do the marrying of
your title i want to mention here on so
if you don't have the third-generation
then you are a production system thermo
also have commercial available while
power link you are affecting mix with
optimized plasma ratio so what you only
need to do is to construct your gene of
interest into the polenta expression
plasmid and code trans factors construct
with the wall power pack mimics
typically with the effective in three
thousand we can get about eight to nine
ten to the seventh functional title it
is greatly improvement over Pei and
leave factor in two thousand and we also
developed word eto protocol for this
specific application if you are
interested please follow the link on the
right here it will guide you to the
world eto protocol there for those who
are interested in suspension culture so
we have our next generation air we max
the Navara production system which will
fit your needs were well and here are
some highlights of the system so if the
title of the system will be even higher
it can
which to ten to the eighth tio per meal
and it is easier to manipulate the
system would be smoothly adapted at you
by reactor production which is suitable
for large-scale production industry use
and the current version of the system
the product is IO and the G&G version is
at its full speed and were coming soon
after so in this system we are
introduced several new component which
fit were well into the current workflow
we developed a brand new transaction
reagent called the Le Mans transduction
reagent which is specifically designed
to achieve high transaction efficiency
in high-density sales and the giba
Kawara producing cells was optimized to
growing very high density and maximum
virus yield at the time of transaction
we introduced the early math supplement
this critical element balanced the cell
growth and water production in other
words it's slow down cell division and
we did direct sales Mort was the water
protein synthesis pathway and the after
transaction we developed a single-shot
booster called airway Mets enhancer
which greatly enhanced the cell's
ability to synthesize and secrete more
on wires
so the chemical LD Mets lentivirus
lentiviral production system we
introduced four new element the high
density a war of production cells we
have the supplement to moderate cell
density we have high efficiency
transduction reagent and plus the
boosting enhancer together this system
can yield at least 20 times more lengthy
wires were
than the current system as I mentioned
earlier on this system will be launched
soon this year and if you are interested
in testing our system is currently
available through our beta testing
program and a lot of people are
interested in early production so I can
tell you this system has been validated
for you production and we are actively
developing program that try to optimize
the conditions for a maximum area yield
so in the following section I want to
highlight some of the key features of
the individual component in this product
firstly the sales so for wire wireless
production really the more sales out
they are producing Wireless the higher
the yield our typical water producing
sales can grow up to 11 meeting per meal
without losing viability so in this
particular example I'm showing you here
we grow the cells in different size of
Chicago asked so 125 meal
500 meal or 1 liter as you can tell when
seated at the same density they grow
consistently well and the viability
maintains about 95 percent up to 6 days
and at this time the sales almost
reached 11 eating per meal and at the
time of transaction we introduced early
mass transaction every math supplement
which balances the cell growth and high
wires yield on the Left figures here I'm
showing you the cell culturing with
different amount of the supplement you
can tell with Q later of the supplement
there's not that much effect while too
much it's
is actually better for the sales and we
really found that 5% is very sweet
balance that we we can make maintain the
healthy culture on the right here
so we combine this different amount of
supplement together with the different
production density at 2.5 million per
meal 4 million per meal from 5 5 meeting
per meal what we found that at fault
meeting premier production day stay with
5 percent of the culture supplement give
us the the highest virus yield as
compared to those without any supplement
there's a at least 2-3 times the booster
of the world's production and again if
you put too much of the supplementary it
will have adverse effect on the worst
production as shown on the far right
here column here so now we have the
wires we have the supplement the net
thing is ready to screen a good
transaction reagent and enhancer for
both tasks we use the design was of
experiment or do ye as our powerful tool
which enables to do high throughput
screening from the beginning of the
screening to the last step of validation
the product actually went through
several rounds of screening testing and
analysis and retesting so in the
following I will show you some of our
examples in our development you know the
development process foil we met
transduction agent we really took
advantage of our in-house little
libraries did a very comprehensive
screening try to find a transparent
region that specifically suitable for
this particular
application the pictures the figure I'm
showing you here it's really on the last
several round of screening in our
department meant process here you can
see several these clearly stand out
against the internal control and these
these were not our formula and final
formulation yet in a following
experiment we will combine these DS with
all other components in the product to
already optimize the condition and pick
the maximum to pick the transaction
region that give us the maximum virus
EOD a similar story with the le max
enhancer so our new enhancer formulation
can boost the virus production at least
a tenfold and not only the formulation
itself but we also tested how much the
dose and what the timing to add the
enhancer to really guarantee our system
way it has the best potential to yield
the maximum virus so taking all together
with all the optimize the conditions of
system can yield up to 210 to the ACE
functional titer
/ crude harvest and this panel just
illustrate if this panel is a simple
swap experiment to illustrate individual
component contribution to the system for
example in column two here we simply
replaced our transparent with P I there
as you can tell there's immediate
threefold drop in virus yield on columns
free we replace our supplement and
announcer with the sodium butyrate and
excuse me and the a6 more food decrease
there and on a lot column we are able to
reproduce the published without with two
nitrous F and P I production as you can
easily tell how much fold our system
improvement over the current system
there so now we have the system the next
step is ready to divert comprehensive
but and easier easy to follow protocol
this is summary of our detail protocol
so basically you would see the sales at
3:00 meeting premier the day before
transaction and at the time of
transaction you would add at 5% of the
air we max culture supplement and dilute
the sales to a four million per meal and
this is our production in this tape and
then you do the transaction you simply
prepare diluted transaction reagent and
DEA and combine them incubate for 10
minutes and add the incubation to the
sales and till to 16 hours after
transaction this is typically the next
morning you would come in to add the
four percent of the air we Maxine Hauser
and 48 hours you host your inverse now
excuse me
now paste on developmental stages we
have development developed different
platforms and protocols for to fit your
needs for large-scale screening we have
the 96-well protocol and for pilot
testing or the border use we have wear a
size of a shaker flask production volume
wearing from third
Meo to a hundred meals and we have
developed a protocol for for industry
use we have developed protocol for two
litres thirteen bioreactors and more
protocol are under activity development
for even larger skilled bioreactor
certain parameters or we buy reactors
this is the technical result we can get
from various platform I just mentioned
before so on the on the bottom here it's
a different size of cultural vessels
along with their minimum and maximum
cargo volume and the bar shows you the
functional tighter we can achieve so you
might notice there's a slight slightly
decrease of titers with the increased
volume of production which is common in
practice and the probably due to the due
to slightly changes in culture
conditions like page or of staging or
geometry changes so with more tight
control of these conditions in bar
reactors we are able to yield shape
similar higher similar high yield at the
small shake of mask so this is what the
product will look like
and the key information a list to here
and if you are interested please do not
hesitate the email highlight here and I
have stop here and have to take some
questions
Thank You dr. G for that informative
presentation we will now start the live
Q&A portion of the webinar if you have a
question you'd like to ask please do so
now just click on the green Q&A button
at the lower left of the presentation
window type your question into the box
that appears on your screen
and click on the send button will answer
as many of your questions as we have
time for so let's get started our first
question is can you explain what the
origin of get Co viral production cells
is and does it contain the T antigen oh
it is derived from 293 F sales and the
still doesn't contain T energy
okay thank you next question is the
enhancer animal origin free yes it is
unloaded free and I want to mention that
all the component providing the Qatar
and Morgan free as well
next question for suspension
transfection do we need to change medium
after transfection no that's beauty of
suspension culture you don't need to
change medium and also especially during
cell recovery you are not supposed to
change medium as well so the whole
process so no medium change so it's at
all that it's a big saving to the medium
part as well
okay next question can I keep the DNA
reagent mixture incubated for a longer
time typically we we will keep the
complex station at for five to ten
minutes
but we also tested for even longer for
example 30 minutes one hour and one hour
and a half still has the similar water
seal so it's quite the the complex is
quite stable so you're good to you if
your your application requires more time
it's okay to keep them for longer time
okay next we have what is the LV max
enhancer
it's a preparatory formulation I don't
think I am I have legal obligations I
don't think I can disclose that
okay well if there are no more questions
I would like to once again thank dr. G
for his presentation I would also like
to thank lab roots and thermo Fisher
Scientific for making today's
educational webcast possible additional
questions will be answered and published
on Thermo Fisher Scientific sweb site
you will receive an email notification
when answers are available before we go
I want to let everyone know that today's
webcast will be available for on-demand
viewing through April of 2018 you will
receive an email from lab rosetta you
know when this webcast will be available
for replay please share that
announcement with your colleagues who
may have missed today's live event
that's all for now and thank you for
joining us we hope to see you again soon
goodbye